who's your guys at Celia Cruz in the
Asian Community oh you know what it is
Teresa Tang Teresa Tay
no no dude I'm trying to get [__]
copy or probably no one knows the [__]
[__] my mom is so [__] jam out to
[__] like this every Asian song sounds
the same yeah dude I know the song This
is a massage for sure I don't know when
the Beat Drops
that's her yeah she's cute oh my God she
can get it she can have it dude I'll
leave it in there and I cut it off and I
know I left it in a good [__] place
she can have it oh trick her to let me
do it and then when it's in there it's
in there oh yeah I'll see you later my
guy was it about a nice petite age in
this speak on it brother see you later
let's see some random Asian [__] I don't
even know what it means
[Laughter]
the salute to my Japanese brother right
there